madame mademoiselle monsieur bonjour le
gouvernement de bonn a pris une terrible
décision la nuit dernière il a décidé de
ne pas céder au chantage des membres du
commando qui détiennent 91 innocents en
otages sur l'aéroport de dubaï
je vous dis tout de suite que ce journal
nous allons le faire sous vos yeux car
chaque minute qui passe il y à de
nouveaux éléments qui interviennent et
nous recevons par satellite et en direct
les images de ce décollage car
l'expiration de l'ultimatum avait été
fixé à 13 heures il est 13 heures une
minute et trente secondes
les membres du commando ont donc décidé
de décoller avec les deux tonnes de
carburant qui leur avaient été données
la nuit dernière avec un art odier nous
allons faire le point d'abord de ce qui
se passe en ce moment et ensuite de ce
qui s'est passé au cours des douze
dernières heures nous parviennent
effectivement en direct mais en fait le
décollage a eu lieu 45 minutes c'est à
dire vers 12h15 45 minutes avant
l'expiration de l'ultimatum est là à cet
instant précis c'est donc passé un
élément tout à fait nouveau contre toute
attente le boeing 737 de la lufthansa a
donc décollé les pirates avaient
effectivement demandé le plein de
carburant au lever du jour il avait
également demandé des cartes météo pour
tracer des routes
c'est cela qui correspondait d'ailleurs
la quantité de carburant qu'on leur
avait donné mais en fait leur
détermination d'aller au bout de
l'ultimatum détermination qui avait été
rappelé peu de temps avant cette
décision de décoller ne permettait pas
de penser qu'il partirait si rapidement
alors pourquoi ce changement de cap
pourquoi ce changement dans les plans
des pirates
eh bien je pense si le résultat du choc
de deux intransigeance l'intransigeance
à la fois des autorités de bonnes et
également de celle de dubaï car depuis
le début de la matinée
les observateurs avaient remarqué que
les moyens militaires s'étaient
sérieusement renforcés sur
le terrain de dubaï jeep avec des
mitrailleuses jour celle cela arrive et
des armes également à tir rapide enfin
il semblait que apparemment un assaut
était peut-être en préparation et
peut-être que les terroristes
ont-ils eu peur que l'intransigeance de
bonn ne débouche précisément sur un
assaut à dubaï fait ça car pour résumer
ce qui s'est passé cette nuit voilà
l'avion qui décolle nous recevons
toujours ces images en direct mais ce
décollage s'est produit effectivement il
ya quarante-cinq minutes
l'avion maintenant se dirigeraient
d'après nos informations vers une île à
la raudière alors on vient d'en recevoir
la confirmation c'est le chef du
commando le capitaine mohamed qui
lui-même a donné cette confirmation à la
tour de contrôle de dubaï en effet
l'appareil se dirigerait vers l'île de
masirah c'est une île qui est situé au
large du sultanat de oman où il faut
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé la nuit
dernière pour bien comprendre qu'elle
doit être l'horrible attentes l'horrible
incertitude pour ses 91 innocent enfermé
dans cet avion que vous voyez décoller
sur votre écran de télévision
le gouvernement allemand a donc décidé
semble-t-il de ne pas céder au chantage
il y avait deux ultimatums le premier ce
matin expiré à 9 heures il s'agissait de
l'ultimatum fixé par les ravisseurs du
patron des patrons allemand monsieur
schleyer et le gouvernement allemand n'a
pas libéré les membres de la bande à
baader donc théoriquement le monsieur
schleyer risque d'avoir été exécutés par
les commandos de l'armée rouge et le
deuxième ultimatum avait été fixé par
les auteurs du détournement d'avion que
vous avez vu décoller à l'instance était
13 heures
il est donc maintenant 13h04 et il est
évident que pour ses 91 innocents qui
sont à bord 86 passagers et cinq membres
d'équipage
ce doit être une attente absolument
épouvantable on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
vont faire et je voudrais que avec alain
rodier en reviennent un petit peu sur ce
qui s'est passé au cours des douze
dernières heures de ce point de vue là
oui effectivement ça a été un compte à
rebours particulièrement angoissant et
dramatique que les sept enfants les 47
femmes et les 33 hommes de l'avion
prison de dubaï ont vécu cette nuit et
ce matin car à aucun moment les pirates
n'ont fléchi à aucun moment ils n'ont
modifié leur attitude intransigeante
au contraire et pourtant depuis hier
dans la tour de contrôle
comité de négociation que président de
le ministre de la défense des émirats
arabes unis à réclamer inlassablement la
libération des otages ou au moins une
concession en priorité pour les malades
et les enfants et cette nuit une voiture
munie d'un mégaphone s'est rendu au pied
de l'avion pour permettre aux
négociateurs de poursuivre les
pourparlers plus directement une
ambulance s'était même arrêté un peu
plus loin feux allumés et moteur en
marche
au cas où une évacuation était permise
mais en vain la tentative échouée à
nouveau parmi les otages il y à un
diabétique et une femme cardiaque qui
doit rester sur surveillance médicale
constante alors sur ces images vous
voyez en fait ce qu'il s'est passé dans
les dernières heures qui ont précédé le
décollage savait être au tour 2 heures
du matin il s'agissait sans doute des
derniers préparatifs de décollage en
début de soirée reprenons le fil des
événements sur ce qui s'est passé cette
nuit en début de soirée les terroristes
avaient déjà montré leur fermeté et leur
état de tension nerveuse extrême en
ouvrant le feu sur le véhicule qui
apportait le générateur destiné à
remettre en marche le climatiseur de
l'avion victime d'une panne
d'électricité
finalement l'opération heureusement
aboutir à plus tard et après trois
heures d'interruption le courant sera
rétabli permettant la remise en route
des climatiseurs à l'aube
c'est à dire en fait à l'heure
précisément où la chaleur re devient
insupportable sans climatiseur il faut
le préciser
la température intérieure de l'avion
atteindre et très vite 50 degrés puis
vers 6 heures du matin regain de tension
les pirates réclament le plein le cheikh
ben rached demande alors qu'en
contrepartie malades femmes et enfants
soit évacué réponse des pirates
nous exécuterons le commandant de bord
et deux passagers à 8 heures si vous
nous refusez le plein et au delà de
cette limite nous exécuterons un otage
toutes les cinq minutes
finalement et bien le commando obtiendra
le ravitaillement en carburant sans
contrepartie ravitaillement qui lui
permettra un rayon d'action semble-t-il
de 2000 à 2500 km à 7h du matin donc je
vous le disais tout à l'heure le
commando a réclamé une carte météo qui
couvre l un rayon de mille kilomètres
montrant donc dès lors la son intention
effectivement de décoller de l'aéroport
de dubaï est effectivement où ils
avaient vu l'appareil a décollé à 12h15
peu après d'ailleurs il faut le préciser
que le cheikh ben rached et tenter une
nouvelle fois une ultime négociation
pour obtenir libération ou même échange
d'otages toutes demandes qui ont été une
nouvelle fois refusé et à ce moment là
d'ailleurs le chef du commando qui
parlait au micro de poste de pilotage en
direction la tour de contrôler qu'il
n'était plus le capitaine mohamed
atteint d'une extinction de voix mais la
femme arabe l'une des deux femmes arabes
qui font partie du commando qui fait
partie du commando
et bien cette femme au micro a pourtant
confirmé l'ultimatum que nous ne
libèrerons personnes et tous autres amis
voilà pour l'instant donc on vous dit on
ne peut que supputer sur les intentions
du commando horrible attentes aussi pour
les familles de ces quatorze innocent
car décoller et à leurs horribles
attendent pour monsieur schleyer qui est
peut-être encore en vie ou qui a été
abattu on ne sait pas et surtout
horrible attendent pour ses proches le
patron des patrons allemands je vous le
rappelle devait être exécuté ce matin à
9h par ses ravisseurs
si les terroristes de la bande à baader
n'étaient pas libérés le gouvernement du
chancelier schmidt n'a pas cédé et pour
ce gouvernement c'est aussi une terrible
attente de bonnes
bernard welker avancèrent la française
ris la présidence du chansonnier chemin
depuis ce matin devant la chancellerie
beaucoup de même déjà l'objet est celle
des débats passionnés et la situation
des passagers de l'avion et se
trouvaient tout à l'heure à dubaï pour
le moment une prise de l'aso est donc
maintenant totalement exclue puisque
l'avion est en l'air et en tout cas la
nouvelle selon laquelle un commando de
choc de l'armée est elle même se
trouvait à dubaï a été de 20,6 ce matin
la décision de prendre l'assaut de
l'avion reviendrait en tout cas dit on
ici
gouvernement du pays où l'avion se
serait posée pourquoi le gouvernement a
tellement acide opté pour la fermeté et
la cemac il sait qu'en libérant 11
dangereux théorie ils sont peut-être
dans l'immédiat 88 eur faible mais c'est
seulement un père aimerait beaucoup
d'autres termes il permettait sûr que
ben blair et ses amis reviendrai
rapidement l'allemagne reprendre avec
l'argent de la rançon le combat contre
ce qu'ils appellent l'impérialisme
allemand et une offre et à l'heure et
recommencerait à leur livrer papa à la
bombe et les assassine d'autres
relations détournement d'avion ne serait
la plus basse avec furent puisqu'il
resterait finalement toujours un ou deux
théories en prison il pourrait être
libéré
ils font l'opinion publique allemande a
compris maintenant la gravité de lenche
après le premier choc lors de l'annoncé
du détournement de l'appareil au delà
nous font vert tout le monde se plaint
position en faveur de la libération de
gbagbo et de ses amis pour réparer les
touristes du boeing de la lufthansa
aujourd'hui l'homme de la rue sont
d'avoir réalisé qu'une capitulation
devant les terroristes ne signifie rien
d'autre qu'un attachement au terrorisme
et la décision de l'état major de crise
de sacrifier éventuel même s'il le
fallait des otages de l'avion paraît
être soutenue par une majorité même
faibles de nos populations
cette décision pourrait elle être
maintenue si par exemple on voit dans
l'après-midi à la télévision allemande
les otages de l'avion exécuter un par
heure évidemment c'est une question que
l'on se pose
le fils du président du patronat
schleier de laitières remettre dans un
hôtel de francfort il a faim de 75
millions à un émissaire de théorie cette
opération n'a pas pu avoir lieu à la
suite d'une indiscrétion
dans la soirée il devient est alors à la
cour constitutionnelle de karlsruhe de
forcer le gouvernement à libérer les
théories pour sauver la vie de son père
la cour a rejeté dans la nuit fête des
mères 1 précisant que l'état ne veut pas
être contraire à adopter à l'avant une
attitude déterminée face à des théories
sous peine évidemment devoir du
gouvernement plaindre à l'avenir sa
crédibilité
chants distortion jacques monsieur
vallières est il encore en vie à cette
heure-ci ses ravisseurs n'ont en tout
cas pas repris contact avec m payot à
genève qui est dépositaire d'une pomme
étage du gouvernement allemand
l'institut de l'hôpital torcy aussi bien
aux filles au pair le
lors de nos supérieurs que celui des
passagers de l'avion la lufthansa opère
une chose est sûre et qu'aucune
disposition n'a été prise
je vous parle dans les prisons elle même
pour une libération des détenus
ses fruits on a entendu à la prison de
toute la semaine détenus triés par une
fenêtre
bientôt nous serons libres à l'heure
qu'il est rien n'est mois sûr avoue pas
voilà pour le point de la situation sur
cette tragique fait il est évident que
si nous avions d'autres éléments nous
vous les communiquerons au cours de ces
journées de ce journal ou même au cours
de l'après-midi avant journal de 20
heures une autre prise d'otages s'est
bien terminée au japon deux terroristes
qui se réclamait de l'armée rouge
unifiée avait pris 16 personnes en otage
dans un autobus
la police a donné l'assaut les 16
passagers sont sains et saufs
un terroriste a été tué l'autre est
prisonnier monsieur raymond barre le
premier ministre a accordé une interview
à notre confrère l'express qui paraîtra
demain il faut élargir la majorité de
telle sorte qu'un consensus national
aussi large que possible puisse être
obtenu a dit monsieur raymond barre il
faut donc ne pas rechercher une autre
majorité expliqué le premier ministre
mais l'élargir le conseil national du
parti républicain poursuit ses travaux
aujourd'hui à paris sur place alain
chaigneau bien si le projet républicain
est assurément assez intéressant il est
sans doute moins ambitieux tout de même
que nous lui souhaiter les dirigeants de
ce parti c'est un projet qui rassemble
mais j'y reviendrai plus longuement ce
soir leur édition de 20 heures une
vingtaine de propositions concrètes qui
touchent directement à la vie
quotidienne des français son but est
clair donner à tous et en dépit de la
crise une vie meilleure
construire un autre progrès pour une
france plus forte et plus unie et pour
parler comme jean pierre soisson donné
aux hommes et aux femmes de ce pays à la
fois des racines et un horizon tout cela
derrière le président de la république
derrière valérie giscard d'estaing qui
est l'élu toute la nation qui est
l'homme en charge de l'essentiel et qui
seul au dessus des partis
émergent quant au parti républicain il
doit lui s'affirmer et grandir encore
pour servir précisément de base
populaire au président de la république
et lui permettre ainsi de poursuivre
l'oeuvre entreprise depuis 74
le courant de mai 1974
c'est la volonté qui est la nôtre d'eau
fait un nouvel horizon
l'avenir ne se rencontrent pas par
hasard il se construit tous les jours
tous les jours non pas référence aux
doctrines au souvenir du passé mais par
la prise on conduira en considération
sans cesse renouvelé de nouvelles
réalités de nouvelles aspirations et ce
n'est pas par hasard que valéry giscard
d'estaing est élu président de la
république en 1974 ce n'est pas par
hasard qu'il a donné le droit de vote
aux jeunes français est aujourd'hui le
parti républicain veut porter plus que
jamais les aspirations de la jeunesse de
notre pays
il veut définir une ambition pour la
france ce faisant il explore en l'avenir
pour le connaître mais nous le disons
aussi nettement pour créer l'avenir
émouvante cérémonie du souvenir ce matin
au cimetière militaire national de
lorette dans le pas de calais le corps
d'un soldat inconnu tombé en afrique du
nord a été inhumé en présence du
président de la république monsieur
giscard d'estaing sur place l'envoyé
spécial de tf1 jacques hébert unir dans
un même souvenir toutes les générations
d'anciens combattants tenter de
réconcilier définitivement les français
sur un conflit encore très présent dans
les mémoires
ce sont je crois les deux principaux
objectifs de valéry giscard d'estaing
qui est donc venu ce matin à notre dame
de lorette ici tout près d'arras lorsque
le cercueil transportés par six anciens
combattants d'algérie est arrivé ici
ils étaient plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'anciens combattants avoir
fait le chemin venus de tous les
départements de france
cérémonie simple mais extrêmement
émouvante dépôt de gerbe par des enfants
prières oecuméniques chants religieux
d'une chorale d'arras et avant que le
cercueil ne soit porté dans la crypte de
l'ossuaire de notre dame de lorette
discours du chef de l'état valéry
giscard d'estaing a tenu à rendre
hommage à
tous les anciens combattants et bien
entendu aujourd'hui tout spécialement
aux anciens combattants d'algérie mais
je vous propose d'écouter les principaux
extraits du discours du président de la
république
chaque fois qu'il honore la mémoire de
ceux qui sont morts pour sa liberté et
son honneur le peuple français retrouve
la source de son unité
quinze ans après un drame qui a
douloureusement diviser les français
nous devons continuer en penser les
plaies afin qu'elles se referment
complètement un jour nous le faisons en
nous associant solennellement a rendu à
l'hommage rendu par leurs camarades et
leurs parents à ceux qui sont tombés en
algérie
nous devons le faire aussi en
accroissant notre effort de solidarité à
l'égard de ceux qui ont été arrachés à
cette terre et qui continue à souffrir
de ce déracinement
je veux dire les rapatrier au cas
l'impact national est aujourd'hui
proposée pour assurer leur réintégration
définitive dans la communauté nationale
que le soldat inconnu d'afrique du nord
notre jeune frère dont le nom s'est
perdue reste toujours dans notre
souvenir comme un exemple et une leçon
voilà je voudrais revenir un instant sur
le gros titre que nous avons longuement
développé au début de ce journal le chef
du commando qui contrôle le boeing 737
de la lufthansa a bien précisé confirmé
que la destination de l'appareil à bord
duquel se trouve je vous rappelle 87
otages et cinq membres d'équipage
étaient l'île de masirah au large du
sultanat
dauman je vous donne rendez vous ce soir
à 20 heures pour le prochain journal
mais il est bien
dans que si des éléments nouveaux
intervenez dans la sphère des
terroristes de la bande à baader
vous seriez immédiatement informé merci